Landing a role in a superhero movie comes
with more than just a nice paycheck and a
steady work opportunity.
Actors are now expected to get in superhuman
shape for action roles, and Margot Robbie
as Harley Quinn is no exception.
Here's how she got into havoc-wreaking shape.
Of course Margot Robbie is fully dedicated
to playing Harley Quinn now, but she originally
got the role without even having to convince
anyone she wanted it.
The actress told MTV News that the team behind
Suicide Squad approached her with the role,
offering her the part without even having
to audition.
"I actually got offered this one, I didn't
audition, which is a real step up as an actor
when you can get offered things."
As it turns out, the producers were captivated
by Robbie's performance alongside Will Smith
in the 2015 movie Focus.
Smith was already locked in to play Deadshot,
and Suicide Squad wanted to recreate that
connection when they cast their Harley Quinn.
"I guess they knew that Will and I worked
well together, so that was a given.
We didn't have to do chemistry reads or anything
like that."
The studio's gamble paid off, and while the
overall reviews for Suicide Squad were less
than enthusiastic, the dynamic between Smith
and Robbie was a consistent high point of
the film.
"You're my friend too."
"Stay evil, dollface."
Margot Robbie is already in pretty great shape,
thanks to working out four or five times a
week for an hour each session, according to
Hollywood personal trainer Andie Hecker.
To get in fighting shape for her comic book
movie, however, she ramped that up to three
hours per day.
As part of a ballet-based fitness program
that Hecker operates, Robbie worked out in
three-hour blocks nearly every day for three
weeks while filming Suicide Squad.
Hecker told People magazine that the focus
on Harley's body and her skimpy costume pushed
Robbie to work out that much harder.
According to Hecker,
"There's a scene in Suicide Squad where she
changes clothes in front of a bunch of dudes,
so her abs needed to be impeccable.
And in those tiny shorts Harley wears, her
butt was constantly on display."
The parts of Robbie's body that were onscreen
for most of Suicide Squad became the focus
of her tailored workouts.
Hecker came up with an exercise routine that
would transform Robbie from a glamorous starlet
into the tough and acrobatic Harley Quinn.
According to Hecker,
"[Margot] wanted to lean out and tone up.
She’s already slender, but we wanted to
make her a little stronger.”
To achieve these goals, most of Robbie's workout
regimen consisted of non-bulking cardio exercises
like ballet jumps.
As a former dancer who runs a ballet training
program, Hecker told People that the jumps
ballet dancers perform are, quote, "surprisingly
the most challenging form of cardio I have
ever come across."
But despite the relative difficulty of the
exercises, Hecker said that Robbie rarely
ever faltered in her commitment to the routine.
Hecker compared Robbie to a machine when she
spoke to the Los Angeles Times.
The actress' workouts apparently resembled
dance marathons, where other clients of Hecker's
would steadily throw in the towel while Robbie
kept at it, relentlessly.
Hecker shared that,
"Other people would try [the workout] along
with us.
But she kept going when other people were
dropping off.
It's so challenging to keep up that level
of intensity, but she powered through it."
Hecker also ran the actress through a weightlifting
regimen intended to tone her butt, thighs
and legs.
She spoke of Robbie's workout on a granular
level in the lead-up to Suicide Squad's release,
telling publications the exact types of exercises
Robbie went through while trying to embody
Harley Quinn.
She said that they went for a lower number
of reps with more weight, a focus on form,
and engaging the correct muscle groups.
In an interview with The Hollywood Reporter,
Hecker explained,
"She had to look sexy and strong.
We'd do lower reps, so 20 leg lifts with that
ankle weight on and then take a break to move
on to the other leg to do another 20, making
sure her glutes were doing it and not her
hamstrings."
If that robotic intensity is making you feel
like you'll never be able to attain a form
like Margot Robbie's, don't worry.
While Hecker painted a picture of the actress
as an ultra-dedicated workhorse in the gym,
Robbie herself revealed that she is far from
disciplined when it comes to her diet.
In an interview with Emirates Woman, Robbie
admitted that she can't handle calorie-cutting
diets, and that cutting delicious and fatty
foods from her life makes her "miserable."
"I'm not good at doing moderation.
I can't just have a salad every day and a
half a glass of wine every second day.
I can't do it."
Robbie told the publication that her diet
largely consisted of beer, fries and burgers,
which she burned off in the gym.
She added that she has a rather unhealthy
way of cutting weight quickly, if a role calls
for it, saying,
"If I have to get in a bikini then I'll eat
carrot sticks for three days.
I'm one extreme or the other."
Successfully pushing to get a standalone Harley
Quinn movie made meant that Robbie had to
get back into Suicide Squad shape, in which
she was able to perform most of her own stunts.
According to Suicide Squad co-producer Andy
Horwitz,
"Margot does 97% of her own stunts in this
movie.
She embraced everything we threw at her, she
makes it her own and does it better than we
could've ever assumed it was going to be."
However, when it came to revisiting Harley
for Birds of Prey, Robbie said many of the
stunts in the new film were actually too dangerous
to take on.
"There's a lot of really cool stunts in the
Birds Of Prey movie.
Quite a few of them, I couldn't do, because
they were just too risky."
That's not to say that Robbie slacked off
in comparison to her work for Suicide Squad,
though.
In addition to regular workouts, Robbie trained
to roller skate ahead of Birds of Prey, after
already learning to ice skate for her role
in I, Tonya.
Photos of Robbie training and shooting in
roller skates circulated on comic book blogs
ahead of the movie's release, revealing that
Prey will be based on a later version of Harley
Quinn modeled after roller derby players.
The roller-skating Harley Quinn comes from
the New 52 reboot in the DC Universe, which
remodeled many characters with a hard refresh
of 52 titles.
Even a newish character like Quinn was not
immune from the mandate.
The most recent version of Quinn has been
completely removed from the Joker, as she
finally split with the Clown Prince of Crime
for good.
With her newfound independence, Quinn's motivations
have also shifted.
Where before most of her actions could be
explained as working for "Mr. J," the newly
single Quinn is considerably less villainous.
She's become a sort-of antiheroic vigilante,
toeing the line between criminal and superhero
while attempting to hold her home of Coney
Island together.
The new Quinn is in the mold of wisecracking
weirdos with murky morals like Deadpool, and
screenwriter Christina Hodson even cited the
"Merc with a Mouth" when she talked about
her early talks with Margot Robbie around
the film.
Robbie's dedication to the character is bound
to translate to the big screen once again,
as it did in Suicide Squad.
And considering that Birds of Prey's reviews
are a big improvement over the reaction to
Suicide Squad, it's likely that we will be
seeing Robbie as a ripped Harley Quinn for
years to come.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.